j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
ce sens public consacré au rôle de la
Turquie dans le conflit au Proche Orient
souvent présenté comme un médiateur
potentiel recepte Erdogan multiplie les
critiques contre Israël il affiche
également son soutien ramas quelle est
sa stratégie pourquoi le président turc
attise le feu avant d'en débattre Fabien
REER revient sur les cartes que la
Turquie abat depuis un mois dans la
région Anthony blinken en visite à
Ankara lundi signe de la mauvaise
entente avec son allié turc le
secrétaire d'État américain n'a pas été
reçu par le président Erdogan ce dernier
vient de célébrer avec Fast le
centenaire de la nation turque au
lendemain d'une manifestation géante de
soutien au Palestiniens à l'appel de
trois partis islamistes dont l' capé le
parti
présidentiel le massacre de Gaza est
totalement l'œuvre de
l'Occident l'Occident je vous interpelle
avez-vous l'intention de relancer le
conflit entre le croissant et les
croisé un discours antioccidental assumé
dans la bouche d'un président qui
qualifiait fin octobre les membres du
Hamas de libérateurs qui protègent leur
terre Turquie et Israël étai pourtant en
voie de normalisation de leur relation
en 2022 les deux pays renouaient des
liens diplomatiques mais l'attaque du 7
octobre a fait voler en éclat ce
processus en endossant le rôle de
champion de la cause palestinienne
contre Israël et l'Occident recheb
taiperdan sert avant tout des ambitions
de politique intérieure analyse cette
chercheuse franco-turque l'ambition de
d'Erdogan et de changer la nature
l'identité l'ADN de la Turquie de faire
oublier de de refermer la parenthèse
atatur mustfha Kemal
laïcité un pays tour vers l'Occident un
pays avec des meœurs
occidentales il veut vous faire oublier
cette cet épisode là et insister sur le
caractère musulman de de de la Turquie
Ankara partenaire difficile mais
incontournable pour les occidentaux en
raison aussi de son poids dans le
dossier ukrainien si elle traîne des
pieds pour autoriser l'adhésion de la
Suède à l'OTAN la Turquie a joué un rôle
clé dans l'accord séréalier qui permet
au blé ukrainien de circuler en mer
Noire malgré la guerre elle livre aussi
à l'Ukraine les fameux drones de combat
baraakar symbole des nouvelles ambitions
turques pourquoi le président Erdogan
attise le feu de la guerre au
Proche-Orient en débat avec Didier bidon
bonsoir bienvenue bonsoir vous êtes
directeur adjoint de l'Institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques Liris spécialiste du
Moyen-Orient et auteur avec Christophe
Ventura de ce livre
desésoccidentalisations repenser l'ordre
du monde qui vient de paraître aux
éditions Agon Jean-François Colosimo
bonsoir et bienvenue historien essayiste
auteur de ce livre le sabre et le turban
publié aux éditions du SER et également
réalisateur du documentaire Turquie
nation impossible on attend Claude Gubal
qui on l'espère reporteur à la rédaction
internationale de Radio France va
pouvoir s'extirper des bouchons
parisiens on verra bien laticia crupa
éditoriste politique évidemment est
resté à mes côtés on on va longuement
parler de de la Turquie évidemment de la
stratégie de Recep TP Erdogan
je voudrais quand même vous entendre sur
cette déclaration de Benjamin netanahou
hier soir sur la chaîne américaine ABC
News il affirme qu'après la guerre son
pays prendra pour une durée indéterminée
la responsabilité générale de la
sécurité autour de la bande de Gaza did
bon comment vous analysez cette prise de
de parole cette prise de position de du
Premier ministre israélien je pense
qu'il y a un grand effet de
communication l'impression que nous
avons malheureusement et pour le pire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les dirigeants
israéliens
encore sous le cou de l'émotion du drame
du 7 octobre mène une politique de la
terre brûlée mais non pas un véritable
projet politique c'est-à-dire que cette
guerre et le plusutôt sera le mieux bah
elle se terminera mais aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que personne n'a
véritablement une idée très précise et
au demeurant pas seulement les
dirigeants israéliens de ce qui se
passera le jour ou les jours d'après
donc dire qu'il prendra en compte la
sécurité de la bande de Gaza je
l'entends je l'écoute mais il me convain
à guerre parce que chacun comprend qu'il
n'y aura pas de solution militaire ni
sécuritaire même si les aspects
sécuritaires ont bien sûr leur
importance mais que la question elle est
fondamentalement politique c'est-à-dire
comment pourra-t-on relancer un
processus de dialogue avec la partie
palestinienne probablement sous égide
internationale tous les scénarios sont
possibles mais en tout cas jouer un peu
les Matam mors en disant que il prendra
en charge la sécurité de Gaza me paraît
au mieux un effet d'annonce et au pire
contreproductif aujourd'hui parce que
les réactions dans la région sont très
négatives sur cette déclaration
Jean-François Colosimo il s'adresse à
qui Benjamin netanahou quand il dit ça
il s'adresse peut-être d'abord aux
Israéliens encore traumatisé par les les
attaques terroristes du 7 octob
s'adresse aussi il s'adresse je pense
d'abord aux États-Unis ouais pour
montrer quel est son but de guerrez que
B don lui a demandé pour quels objectifs
bah il fixe ses objectifs cet objectif
il sous-entend la sécurité c'est une
prérogative c'est un attribut de la
souveraineté donc il sous-entend que
finalement il r d'un trait il annule les
accords d'Oslo qui reconnaissaiit un
statut à Gaza il annule le retrait
israélien il le renverse de 2005
n'est-ce pas et il annule aussi au
passage une théorie qui avait été
esquissée que c'est il allait revenir à
l'Autorité palestinienne à marmoudabas
de finalement reprendre gazas puisque le
but étant d'éradiquer le Hamas et Gaza
étant sous le contrôle du Hamas il est
évident que il fallait bien qu'il y ait
une autorité bon mais je pense que là de
ce point de vue là il dit tout
simplement et c'est l'horizon de la paix
qui recule du même coup c'est clair il
dit que cet aspect sécuritaire va
prendre le pas sur tous les autres et
que ddormé en
fait Israël là pour le coup va
réellement occuper Gaza qui encore une
fois internationalement avait un statut
certes en devenir mais qui un statut
tout de même au moins
d'autonomie donc ça veut dire le point
de départ du futur État palestinien oui
enfin le futur État oui pu aussi en S
Jordanie à ramala mais on sait
l'impuissance en fait du fata de de
l'héritage de Yasser Arafat et donc de
ce point de
vue-là si vous voulez on pense pas qu'il
va ramener avec les soldats les Juifs
qui s'étaient implantés les Israéliens
qui s'étaient implantés à Gaza et dans
les installation les impl avait été
démantelé en en 2005 mais c'est l'idée
que en fait et c'est ça le véritable
problème de cette guerre j'en suis
d'accord avec dis billon c'est que c une
guerre elle suppose pour être juste
plusieurs critères mais le critère
ultime
c'est la paix après la guerre bon alors
il est vrai qu'il est dans une situation
dans laquelle il a guerre
d'interlocuteur le Hamas ne l'est pas
pour lui et on le comprend très bien
après ce qui s'est passé le 7 octobre al
côté l'autorité l'Autorité palestinienne
mmoud Abbas a été encore une fois
l'héritier de l'OLP a été complètement
dévitalisé délégitimé donc cette idée de
on va s'occuper de la sécurité c'est une
manière de dire aussi que les
bombardement auront une suite
d'apparence de paix civile mais sous en
fait le pouvoir de l'armée israélienne
ve dire mais je repose la la question de
de de de l'opinion publique israélienne
million c'est peut-être son avenir
politique aussi que joue Benyamin
netanyah parce que la la majorité qu'il
avait à la cessette avant avant les les
attaques terroristes du 7 octobre pas
sûr qu'il la qu'il la retrouvera cette
majorité quand la guerre sera terminée
non on se souvient que dans la période
qui précède le 7 octobre il y avait eu
38 semaines de manifestations en Israël
qui était clairement dirigé contre les
projets de réforme du Tribunal
constitutionnel l'équivalent du Conseil
constitutionnel français si comparaison
vaut ça c'est extraordinairement
important c'était des manifestations qui
est équivalente à la population
française rassemblait plus de 10
millions de personnes si on fait un
rapport un ratio il est évident que
cette partie de l'opinion publique n'est
pas favorable à netaniaou mais de plus
le 7 octobre au-delà de la tragédie de
l'horreur que tout le monde peut
partager une bonne partie des Israéliens
rendre netanou responsable de cette
situation lui qui prétendait assurer la
sécurité à tous ses concitoyens à tous
les juif vivant en Israël bah il a
malheureusement prouvé que ce n'était
pas le cas donc il parle à sa base
électorale quand il dit je on va assurer
la sécurité de la bande de il essaie de
resserrer les rangs alors aujourd'hui
les rangs sont assez resserrés pour des
raisons évidentes parce que c'est
l'émotion qui prime et probablement
quand on fait des sondages en Israël
aujourd'hui il y a une majorité qui veut
en découdre avec le
è qu' décé lui ministr
depuisobre qu'il voulait éradiquer le
Hamas alors il peut porter des coups
très durs militairement Hamas mais il ne
peut pas éradiquer le Hamas parce que
par définition c'est le type
d'organisation qu'on ne peut pas
éradiquer ce que je crains beaucoup pour
ma part pour l'après et j'arrête là
c'est que le Hamas dans 10 ans on va se
dire ah il était un peu modéré parce que
devant l'horreur devant l'INT CIT des
bombardements et les dégâts que ça fait
dans les populations civiles je crains
fort que des hommes et peut-être des
femmes totalement désespéré sans avenir
se radicalise encore plus que ce que le
Hamas n'a fait on parle de la Turquie
vouliez reprendre la parle dire que très
rapidement en fait oui effectivement je
pense que si on faisait un sondage
d'opinion il y a 90 % des Israéliens qui
sont tout à fait avec l'idée que il faut
se débarrasser du Hamas mais il y a une
forte proportion d'Israéliens aussi
très importante qui compte réclamer des
comptes à à netania ça il faut bien se
rendre compte que une opp n'empêche pas
l'autre et dans cette fameuse
déclaration il conclut d'ailleurs sur le
fait que la question de sa
responsabilité dans le 7 octobre a été
posée et qu'il entend y répondre et que
clairement oui il y a eu une forme de
défaillance ce qui veut dire que lui
aussi joue son avenir politique à
travers cette question mais il n'est pas
sûr que le 7 octobre n'est pas provoqué
une espèce de de il n'est pas
complètement rebattu les cartes en fait
en Israël parce qu'effectivement c'était
l'aboutissement d'une crise profonde
entre Israéliens religieux et laïque
pour aller vite autour de la Cour
suprême et de ce point de vue-là
peut-être que netanahou est déjà un
homme du passé allez on s'intéresse au
rôle de de la Turquie et de son
président dans ce conflit au au Proche
Orient c'est évidemment le thème central
de notre débat il nous reste allez un
peu plus de de 30 minutes pour pour
l'analyser première question dididier
bon pourquoi Recep TP Erdogan est
aujourd'hui aussi violent je dis bien
aujourd'hui aussi violent dans ces
attaques contre Israël alors il y a
plusieurs raisons probablement il y a
tout d'abord des raisons de politique
intérieure nous savons que Erdogan a
toujours ce don si je puis dire de mêler
les enjeux de politique extérieure avec
les enjeux de politique intérieure et
son obsession permanente c'est de souder
les rang de renforcer sa base électorale
et sa base social de ce point de vue
nous le savons en Turquie avec ou sans
erdoan c'est bien antérieur à son
arrivée au pouvoir qui date de
maintenant plus de de 20 ans il y a une
empathie majoritaire au sein de la
population turque à l'égard de leurs
frères palestinien à l'égard de la cause
palestinienne ça c'est une certitude et
Erdogan a ce don de surfer sur ce qu'il
perçoit des processus de fond au sein de
sa
société conjoncturellement
rappelons-nous qu'il y a des élections
municipales au printemps prochain au MO
de mars prochain 2024 et que dès le soir
du 28 mai pourquoi le 28 mai c'est le
soir de absolument le soir même c'est
très étonnant dans sa première
déclaration il explique bon on n'arrête
pas là ENF je vous l' fait courte on
n'arrête pas là le prochain objectif
c'est de reconquérir nos villes les
villes qu'il a perdu aux dernières
élections capit alors c'est la capitale
économique Istanbul mais au combien
symbolique pour des raisons évidentes et
la capitale politique enkara et puis il
y a Ismir aussi mais qui
traditionnellement est au mains de
l'opposition ça c'est la première raison
je pense qu'il y a une raison régionale
on sait aussi qu'une des des obsessions
ou un des axes de la part de Erdogan
c'est d'apparaître comme une puissance
incontournable voire même d'apparaître
comme puissance leader dans la région or
il a parfaitement compris que cette
empathie pour la question palestinien
all est largement partagé dans la
quasittalité des États de la région
j'entends par là le Moyen-Orient bien
évidemment il pense par ces déclarations
extrêmement dures aujourd'hui parce
qu'elles étaient beaucoupou
venirb ça et puis dernier élément très
vite bah c'est sur le champ
international parce que je considère que
la Turquie elle fait partie de ces états
dit du Sud je mets des guillemets à
l'expression mais qui sont actuellement
en train de s'émanciper de ce qu'il
considérait comme la tutelle occidentale
et quand on regarde une carte du monde
on voit que cette question palestinienne
engendre beaucoup de sympathie au-delà
même du monde musulman on voit quand
même des manifestations nombreuses varié
à travers le monde y compris d'ailleurs
dans certaines puissances occidentales
vous voyez il y a un agenda qui est à
plusieurs niveaux mais qui permettent à
mon avis de comprendre pourquoi il y a
cette radicalisation du discours de
Erdogan et c'est le thème de de votre de
votre livre évidemment la
désoccidentalisation il faut toujours
prendre son souffle avant de avant de
prononcer ce mot je propose à à Quentin
calm de nous rejoindre tout de suite
parce qu'on va effectivement revenir sur
les principales déclarations du du
président turc rebonsoir Quentin on peut
dire que récep Erdogan souffle un peu le
chaud et le froid depuis un mois oui
c'est vrai les premières prises de
parole de récep Tayip Erdogan ont été
relativement mesuré après les attentats
prenant la désescalade aussi prêchant en
faveur de la paix le glissement s'est
opéré semble-t-il mi-octobre après le
bombardement de l'hôpital Al Ali de Gaza
malgré les enquête qui pointe bien vers
le jjihad islamique un groupe armé
palestinien Erdogan s'en prend à Israël
il le fait devant 600 les 600 députés
Turcs il dit à ce moment-là qu'il annule
son voyage prévu dans les prochaines
semaines en Israël écoutez la
suite
Hamas
TER pas un groupe de
terroristes c'est un groupe de
libérateurs et de mid qui se battent
pour protéger le terre et leurs
citoyens
gr le président tur qui a une position
ambigu on peut le dire selon le média en
ligne al monitor le chef de la branche
politique du Hamas Ismaël Anet il se
trouvait à Istanbul au moment de
l'attaque du 7 octobre il aurait été
invité à ce momentl à quitter la Turquie
par les autorités après la publication
de photos de lui et d'autres membres du
Hamas en train de prier devant les
images des attaques en Israël diffusé à
la télévision des informations que le
gouvernement turc réfute totalement mais
d'autres médias ont également publié des
articles dans ce sens et pour conclure
on peut dire que la Turquie cherche en
quelque sorte sa place sur l'échiquet
diplomatique c'est cela Erdogan aimerait
être un acteur important aussi dans la
résolution de la crise au Proche Orient
il est en fait écartelé entre l'alliance
avec les américains notamment via l'OTAN
et les partis islamistes au sein de son
pays vous en parlez il y a quelques
instants qui pousseent pour un soutien
plus ferme envers le Hamas le président
turque qui aura besoin de la voix de ses
partis lors des prochaines élections
municipales de 2024 merci beaucoup
Quentin Jean-François colossimo pour
pour comprendre les liens
entre Recep taip Erdogan et le ramas il
faut évidemment parler des Frères
musulmans qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire
il partagent quoi la même idéologie pour
moi oui il y en a qui le conteste on
mais il est clair de toute façon que
pendant très longtemps le Hamas n'a en
fait été que la branche palestinienne
des Frères musulmans d'Égypte et
d'ailleurs l'attentisme du Hamas
jusqu'en
1987 sa difficulté rentrer en action
même si çaappelait pas encore le Hamas
mais cette branche là dépendait beaucoup
de la situation assez difficile des
Frères musulmans en Égypte lorsqu'on se
rend au Qatar par exemple on sait que
c'est le Qatar qui ass sur les fins de
mois du
vraisemblablement d'ailleurs avec je
dirais une sorte de bénédiction discrète
de Washington et même de tel vive
puisque tout sarrangeait un peu tout le
monde que le Qatar paix et assure un
semblant de stabilité sociale en fait
très menacé dans Gazin bien lorsqu'on se
rend au Qatar on voit des portraits
d'Erdogan partout or vous savez que le
Qatar a subi l'ostracisme de l'Arabie
Saoudite et des émirats euh Arabe Unis
parce que la ligne des émirats
et de l'Arabie Saoudite c'est le
salafisme pourquoi parce que le
salafisme n'a pas toujours al on dans la
nébuleuse de l'islamisme mais le
salafisme n'a pas toujours une
revendication de prise du pouvoir
souvent les salafistes en fait se
contentent de situations qui leur
permettent l'exercice complet de leur
piété alors que les Frères musulmans
c'est pas le cas des Frères musulmans
c'est ça ont un projet politique qui est
la prise de pouvoir et de préférence
d'ailleurs prise de pouvoir national qui
ensuite s'étendrait de nation en nation
jusqu'à réformer complètement l'UMA
c'est pour cela qu'on a vu par exemple
que l'Arabie Saoudite et les Émirats
Mohamed Ben Zayed et Mohamed bin Salman
était tout à fait ligué dans le fait de
mettre Morsi dehors c'est-à-dire le
premier président Frères musulmans
d'Égypte à quoi ils sont arrivés le
Qatar s retouvé sitation d'racisme parce
que précisément le Qatar soutient la
ligne des Frères musulmans aussi parce
que le Qatar avait des relations avec
l'Iran d à des gap des na de gaz très
importante bon mais ce Qatar s'est
retrouvé mis sous blocus lorsqu'il a été
mis sous blocus ouz il y des blocus qui
parfois arrive entre arabe lorsqu'il a
été mis sous
blocus il a eu le soutien de de la
Turquie pas que pour des raisons
d'opportunités pour des raisons aussi
d'affinité malgré tout au fond Erdogan a
commencé comme un frère musulman
n'est-ce pas il est vraiment dans
l'atmosphère frériste avant d'avoir
compris qu'il pouvait gagner euh le
pouvoir
en recourant à la démocratie même si
depuis il a retréi cette démocratie
autant qu'il pouvait donc de ce point de
vue-là quand on le voit et je suis
parfaitement d'accord c'est un immense
politicien fait qu'est-ce qu'il fait il
voit bien que les manifestations
propalestiniennes vont venir il vaut
mieux pour lui en prendre la tête tout
simplement ou et les animer parce que au
fond cette il y a un frérisme
d'atmosphère aussi en Turquie que la
Capp a beaucoup développé faut
comprendre on on on va essayer de
joindre Claude Gubal qui est qui est
toujours dans son taxi et donc on va
essayer de faire ça en en duplexe en en
Skype je rappelle que vous êtes grand
reporteur à la rédaction internationale
de Radio France et on vous invitait
parce que vous avez signé un un podcast
passionnant sur la Turquie titré
intitulé Erdogan la la tentation de
l'Empire j'espère que vous nous entendez
bien et qu'on va bien vous
entendre
également concernant justement le les
liens entre on est sur ce chapitre he
vous nous entendez les liens entre
Erdogan et et le ramas est-ce qu'ils
sont anciens et et et finalement allez
ancré dans la société
turque il y a plusieurs choses en fait
dans votre question je sais pas si vous
m'entendez mais il y a plusieurs choses
dans votre question il y a les lien
entre Erdogan et la question
palestinienne qui est quelque chose qui
lui a toujours été cher
et Erdogan depuis son son arrivée au
pouvoir en Turquie n'a jamais cessé de
faire de cette question un late motif
dans ses relations internationales on se
souvient qu'en 200 au Forum de Davos il
s'était euh violemment opposé à Shimon
Perez qui s'exprimait sur les
bombardements à Gaza euh l'année
d'après la Turquie avait les ONG turqu
avaient affraité des bateaux lors de
l'épisode de la flottille de la liberté
avec ce ce bateau le Mavi Marmara qui
avait été arraisonné par la marine
israélienne dans dans une dans dans une
opération qui avait fait plusieurs morts
côté turc et RB Tayip Erdogan s'est
toujours porté en en héros de la cause
de la cause palestinenne au moment des
printemps arabes donc en en 2011 Erdogan
a vu dans les printemps arabes
l'occasion de se j'allais dire de se
poser en en en en figure en en figure
leader du ProcheOrient sunite et en cela
euh il s'est donc rapproché de tous les
les de tous les mouvements islamistes
qui participaient donc à ces printemps
arabes et donc il a fait le à l'époque
le Paris le Paris des Frères musulmans
en Turquie et c'est à la suite de cela
que il a accueilli en Turquie sur le sol
turc des représentations euh une
représentation du Hamas et les les
dirigeants les dirigeants du Hamas la
direction politique du Hamas qui est
effectivement en partie au Qatar fait
des allers-retours très fréquemment avec
la Turquie où ils sont où ils sont reçus
par par par les officiels de de la CAP h
restez avec nous la liaison est correcte
donc on va revenir vers vous en espérant
que vous finissiez par arriver jusqu'au
Sénat on verra bien c'est un peu le
feuilleton de cette fin d'après-midi
désolé de vous le faire partager mais je
voudrais 10 milons puisquon est sur ces
liens entre Erdogan et le Hamas en fait
il faudrait dire dire des liens entre la
Turquie et le ramas parce que Erdogan
vous nous l'avez dit il est au pouvoir
depuis plus de 20 ans je crois que c'est
mars 2003 quand il devient premier
ministre c'était déjà le cas avant avec
ses prédécesseurs il y avait des des
liens entre la Turquie et enfin la cause
palestinienne pour être un peu un peu
plus binaire quoi alors oui c'est une
histoire compliquée parce que on en
parlait avec Jean-François juste avant
le début de l'émission je rappelle
toujours que la Turquie est le premier
pays culturellement musulman à avoir
reconnu Israël dès 1949 oui alors depuis
lors on n' pas le temps de non on va pas
on va pas pouvoir séquencer toutire une
une autre date quand même
1969 ouais 1969 ce sont les laïes qui
sont au pouvoir c'est même monsieur
jevit et il reçoit Yasser Arafat et il
ouvre un bureau de représentation de
l'OLP à l'époque l'OLP était considéré
commeganisationor absolument d'accord
donc vous voyez il y a eu des beaucoup
de de connexions et et et en fait un jeu
d'aller-retour dans ses relations avec
l'État d'Israël ça c'est la la première
chose mais franchement je considère
comme je disais tout à l'heure que la
Turquie le peuple turc a une immense
Athie à l'égard des Palestiniens et ce
n'est pas réductible à euh à erdoan la
deuxième chose si vous le permettez
c'est sur les relations entre erdoan et
les Frères musulmans oui euh pour ma
part je conteste totalement euh
l'appartenance comme certains l'ont
prétendu pas sur ce plateau de Erdogan
au Frères musulmans il faut bien
comprendre que la matrice et l'histoire
de la confrerie des Frères musulmans
c'est une histoire au départ égyptienne
puis arabe spécifiquement arabe or la
matrice de l'islam politique turque dont
erdoan est un représentant
incontestablement depuis sa prime
jeunesse c'est une autre histoire c'est
avec des racines proprement turques et
nationales turqu et le lien commun c'est
c'est l'islam alors bien évidemment
ensuite pour des raisons politiques il y
a des liens entre Erdogan là je saute
quelques étapes et le mouvement des
Frères musulmans et comme ça a été
rappelé par Claude en
2011-22 Erdogan qui veut absolument
s'imposer comme le leader de la région
il a beaucoup hésité quant à son
attitude par rapport aux révoltes arabes
de 2011-22 et puis finalement il fait le
choix mais là une erreur totale de
perspective c'est de de s'accrocher à la
mouvance des Frères musulmans dont il
pensent que c'est eux qui vont
pardonnez-moi l'expression tirer les
marrons du feu qui vont s'imposer sur
les scènes politiques en Égypte en
Tunisie et cetera ce qui au début le on
pouvait le le l'admettre pu puis très
rapidement pour des raisons évoquées il
y a eu des coups d'État notamment en
Égypte comme tu l'as rappelé bon et donc
euh là il y a une erreur d'appréciation
politique est-ce que pour autant ça veut
dire qu'il n'y a pas de relation avec
les Frères musulmans mais bien sûr il y
en a ils sont régulièrement invité au
congrès de laqui mais derrière la
question que je posais tout à l'heure de
de du du on va dire du commun
idéologique
moi j'ai en tête est-ce qu'il y a une
stratégie commune voyez une volonté
commune de de peser sur la scène
internationale a des liens d'opportunité
il y a des opportunités parce qu'il y a
quand même des liens de sympathie
idéologique c'est c'est c'est là où où
je veux dire si effectivement on va pas
caractériser enfin Erdogan n'est pas un
disciple de Hassan Albana le créateur
des Frères musulmans voilà ça c'est
clair on est parfaitement d'accord en
même temps on y a véritablement je
dirais un mouvement sans tripète qui est
extrêmement fort si ce n'est que Erdogan
lui est à la tête d'un grand pays c'est
c'est une différence et que malgré tout
dans ce pays continue à se tenir des des
élections même si elles sont parfois un
peu chaotiques et parfois souvent
manipulé mais de ce point de vue là donc
autre point il continue à appartenir à
l'OTAN oui donc je crois que cette
réversibilité d'Erdogan on on la voit
cette réversibilité sur l'Ukraine on la
voit cette réversibilité avec Poutine
d'un côté Biden de l'autre Erdogan joue
son jeu mais je crois qu'il joue comme
un joueur de bgamon c'est-à-dire que au
bgamon vous savez différen échecs on
lance les d h et sont les D qui décident
de votre capacité d'avancer et la partie
pe chez Erdogan il y a un véritable pas
au sens moral du terme un véritable
opportuniste ce qui explique est moins
stratège qu'un jouur d'échec si je vous
entends bien bah il est plus dépendant
en fait de la mobilité du jeu donc on a
un Erdogan qui au départ aimerait bien
passer pour l'homme qui va faire la paix
dans la région et se montre l'erdogan
aimable qu'on avait redécouvert après un
Erdogan tempétueux pendant longtemps qui
avait repris sa place et qui d'ailleurs
marquer des points pour la Turquie la
Turquie diplomatiquement marquer des
points de manière et puis d'un coup
voilà le les déroules et ça change et là
il redevient le champion des musulmans
en quelque sorte des musulmans sunnites
opprimés et toutes les décisions prises
toutes ses prises de paroes le sert
finalement sa propagande et son propre
culte de la personnalité qu'il est en tr
train de mettre en place depuis 20 ans
depuis son oui oui parce que les gens du
Hamas certainement devraient se rappeler
qui je veux dire l'histoire des Arabes
sous les Turcs n'a pas été une histoire
tout à fait égalitaireou et puis quand
vous parlez d'opportunisme tiens je vous
propose une image qui le qui
l'illustre aujourd'hui il multiplie les
les diatripes contre Israël le président
turc mais pourtant le 20 septembre
dernier donc on est quoi 2 semaines
peut-être 17 15 16 17 jours avant le les
attaques terroristes du du Hamas il
s'affiche avec Benjamin netaniahou voilà
l'image bien sûr New York en marge de
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies
il parle de des questions
internationales et régionales on va dire
qu'il s'était engagé dans un processus
de de normalisation avec avec
Israël Claude gibal je reviens vers vous
quel est l'intérêt d'Erdogan à ce
moment-là est-ce que c'est d'abord un un
but économique qu'il qu'il recherche en
en s'affichant avec Benyamin netaniahou
est-ce que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça alors alors il y a plusieurs buts
qui sont recherchés mais je il faut pour
cela bien bien entendre ce que vient de
dire Jean-François
colossimo REP Tayip Erdogan est un
incroyable pragmatique un un vrai animal
politique et quand il se rapproche l'été
dernier d'Israël Erdogan fait un calcul
très clair c'est qu'il voit que de gros
pays sunites l'Arabie saoudite a
commencé par elle se rapproche d'Israël
et il faut pas qu'il reste en dehors
d'un jeu qui va finalement servir à des
régimes dont il est concurrent par
ailleurs il y a aussi et c'est c'est pas
un des moindres un des moindres aspects
la question énergétique stratégique du
gaz avec avec Israël et donc Reb Tayip
Erdogan qui n'en est pas un j'allais
dire un retournement de veste prês là se
rapproche de de benjamine netanahou il y
a cette rencontre chaleureuse et qui est
absolument
invraisemblable pour qui a entendu
Erdogan pendant des années déverser sa
sa colère et sa et sa haine d'Israël et
de ses dirigeants ben voilà il y a ce
retournement qui se fait après est-ce
que ça veut dire que c'est pour autant
fini je voudrais rappeler ici que
erdoan après avoir été dans le même
genre de relation avec MBS le prince
héritier saoudien au moment de l'affaire
hashogi notamment s'est réconcilié avec
lui depuis s'est réconcilié avec S
rapproché de Bachar al-Assad donc
j'allais dire pour l'instant Benjamin
netaniaahou
euh le rapprochement avec Benjamin
netanahou n'est plus n'est plus du tout
euh j'allais dire au programme mais les
relations avec Israël ne sont pas pour
autant rompues oui effectivement elles
sont pas rompues donc donc là on était
le 20 septembre évidemment ensuite il y
a l'attaque terroriste du du 7 octobre
Quentin l'expliquait tout à l'heure un
un premier temps on va dire relativement
neutre de du président turc et puis
ensuite il y a des des prises de parole
de plus en plus virulentes et notamment
dans sa façon d'accuser l'Occident
d'être le responsable des morts de Gaza
écoutez vous savez de qui il s'agit
n'est-ce pas je parle de l'Occident de
l'Amérique de l'Europe et de tous ces
pions dont ils tiennent les
ficelles cet Occident que fe le poète
turc
MIF décriv comme la bête qui n'a plus
qu'une
D
MRE seoule à
gaz
[Musique]
enülute batıdır voilà ce jour-l il y a
1500000 manifestants dans dans les rues
d'Istanbul proalestinien évidemment et
c'est lui qui a appelé à cette
manifestation bien sû bien sûr Didier
bon est-ce que on on a rappelé vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure la
position quand même particulière de la
Turquie membre de l'OTAN et
interlocuteur du ramas ça on faisait un
médiateur potentiel pourquoi il se
pourquoi il s cette branche sous lui
vous voyez ce que je veux dire al oui
vous avez parfaitement raison je pense
que au tout début après le 7 octobre il
voulait se poser comme un des médiateurs
et il est vrai qu'il avait des atouts
puisque il avait de bonnes relations
nouvelles certes avec netaniahou mais la
poignée de main nous l'a rappelé et puis
il avait ses relations avec le Hamas
puisqu'on savait qu'une partie des
dirigeants du Hamas pouvaient venir
quand il voulait soit Ankara soit
Istanbul et donc il est en train de
perdre la capacité à jouer ce rô
pourquoi il le fait mais pour les
raisons que j'évoqué tout à l'heure pour
des raisons d'affirmation d'une sorte de
enfin en tout cas c'est ce qu'il espère
de leadership au niveau régional parce
qu'il sait qu'aujourd'hui au vu de ce
qui se passe à Gaza taper au maximum
politiquement contre Israël ne peut-être
que bénéfique et je partage totalement
ce qui a été dit précédemment euh
Erdogan c'est tout sauf un idéologue
alors il a quelques conviction notamment
religieuse bien ancré mais c'est un
pragmatique c'est un opportuniste c'est
c'est pas quelqu'un qui est capable de
se projeter sur les 15 ans à venir il
fait des coups et souvent avec succès au
demeurant et donc aujourd'hui il a
parfaitement compris que pour s'affirmer
encore plus dans la région il est
nécessaire de critiquer le plus
violemment possible netanahou et la
politique dans la région et dans son
pays avant tout qu'on disait tout à
l'heure il y a aussi cet objectif et
n'oublions jamais qu'il y a un jeu en
réalité dans cette région indépendamment
de la crise actuelle il y a un jeu de
concurrence pour savoir qui dans les 15
ans à venir va affirmer son leadership
et il y a une concurrence entre la
Turquie l'Iran l'Arabie Saoudite donc
c'est une des raisons pour laquelle
aujourd'hui il préfèrent jouer la carte
de la bonne entente avec les Saoudiens
avec lesquels il s'est réconcilié avec
les Iraniens je rappelle que le le
ministre des Affaires étrangères iranien
est venu en Turquie pour discuter avec
son homologue après le 7 octobre donc
c'est quand même très important donc
aujourd'hui il joue cette carte de la
coopération peut-être que dans un an 2
ans 5 ans ça sera des rivalités beaucoup
plus aigu donc c'est un homme de coup
avec un P et un s à la fin souvent
réussi au demeurant mais ça ne fait pas
une politique ça n'enracinera pas
réellement la Turquie dans son
environnement géopolitique sur le long
terme j'ouvre un dernier chapitre dans
notre débat sur les liens entre la
France et la Turquie latia les deux pays
on peut parler de relations houleus
depuis plusieurs années est-ce qu'on
peut dire que le dialogue est
aujourd'hui gelé oui on peut dire que
c'est le statut quo aujourd'hui T et
vous êtes quand même c'est un euphémisme
he relation houleuse elles sont
catastrophiques ces relations depuis
2020 alors entre les deux hommes c'est
encore pire ce sont des une vraiment une
relation interpersonnelle très très
compliquée 2020 où Erdogan dit
d'Emmanuel Macron que c'est un politique
minable qu'il
est qu'il est novice en politique et que
il a un problème avec l'islam et les
musulmans il pote du doigt Emmanuel
Macron qui à ce moment-là rappelez-vous
est en train de réfléchir à un projet de
loi sur le séparatisme Erdogan réagit
tout de suite il conseille au président
français de faire des examens pour sa
santé mentale hein c'était quand même
les termes qu'il avait employé ambitieux
incapable aussi on avait lu ça dans dans
dans dans sa voix là aussi on l'a on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure est-ce qu'il
parlait d'abord à à ses électeurs à sa
population Erdogan évidemment il ne
parle pas au français mais il parle à
ses électeurs il parle aux Turcs mais
pas seulement aux Turcs de Turquie il
parle aux Turcs du monde entier il y a
des Turcs dans le monde entier il y a
beaucoup de Turcs en Europe il le sait
et il parle aussi au nom des musulmans
parce qu'il est tente d'incarner tout de
même un certain leadership du monde
musulman pour l'instant ce n'est pas àis
mais c'est son projet alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que l'Élysée se garde
plutôt de réagir oui parce qu'en France
il y a environ 700000 Turcs sur le sol
français donc à l'Élysée on ne sait pas
trop comment réagir pourquoi parce que
on sait que c'est un levier de puissance
pour Erdogan cette communauté turque
mais on craint aussi une révolte une
colère du monde musulmans français dans
son ensemble donc entre les deux pays on
peut dire qu'on avance prudemment
d'ailleurs il y avait un déplacement
d'Emmanuel Macron qui était prévu cet
automne là donc on y est encore hein on
n'est pas encore en hiver ouis ou il est
aussi question peut-être qu'ardan
viennent en France tout ça ça a été
reporté sinédiier h on peut parler d'une
d'une politique pas très claire de la
France de la Turquie est-ce que vous
diriez ça on peut dire que la France
s'est embourbée dans cette politique
pourquoi parce qu'après le séisme de
l'hiver dernier les conseillers de
l'Élysée se sont laissés dire que
finalement le peuple turc allait se
retourner contre Erdogan et qui n'allait
pas être réalu parce que on avait vu
après le séisme toute la corruption du
système d'Erdogan remonter la surface et
tout le monde s'est dit en France ah les
Turcs vont pas le réélir finalement il
emporte 52 % des vosour et finalement il
est est réélu alors que fait Emmanuel
Macron il s'empresse de le féliciter
évidemment au détour d'un tweet rappelle
qu'il y a quand même des intérêts
communs il parle lui de défis hein que
la France et la Turquie doivent relever
il parle de la paix en Europe de l'OTAN
de la Méditerranée h c'est un peu de la
diplomatie ce n'est que de la diplomatie
que de la vitrine he parce que c'est
finalement une relation très complexe
entre les deux hommes entre les deux
pays de contentieux et d'intérêt mêlés
et la vérité c'est que Emmanuel Macron
est un peu bloqué hein parce que lui a
vraiment le souci d'apparaître dans ce
conflit israëlo-palestinien qui
s'importe en France très mesuré de
respecter la communauté musulmane en
France et donc il fait très attention à
ne pas être mal interprété à que ses
propos ne servent pas la propagande d'un
erdoan qui pourrait chauffer à blanc
comme ça quand il le souhaitent les
Turcs en France et puis les musulmans en
France donc finalement on en revient
exactement à ce que je disais sur
Erdogan quand Emmanuel Macron parle
d'Erdogan ou parle avec Erdogan il parle
avant tout lui aussi au français sa
commun et aux électeurs français comment
vous qualifiez Jean-François colisimo
cette relation entre Erdogan et et le
président français Emmanuel Macron moi
je crois pas que ça soit une une
relation craintive de la part du
président français je pense que
l'énervement d'Erdogan contre la France
a des raisons factuel oui c'est que
lorsque Erdogan menace comme il le fait
chaque été les îles greces nous
dépêchons des frégates militaires pour
dire que nous protégeons la Grèce que
nous sommes avec la Grèce n'est-ce pas
lorsque Erdogan avec Ali le président de
l'Azerbaïdjan se propose quand même de
de couper de en petit morceau l'Arménie
nous sommes en train d'étudier euh une
alliance de protection militaire avec
l'Arménie au passage d'ailleurs ce qui a
un peu incompréhensible dans la position
d'Erdogan aujourd'hui c'est que jusque
que là son alliance à l'Azerbaïdjan
faisait de l'Azerbaïdjan en fait pour
Israël une plateforme contre l'Iran et
ça ça allait dans le sens des intérêts
d'Erdogan d'autant plus qu'Israël avait
fourni des armes de très haute précision
à l'Azerbaïdjan qui avait permis de
gagner facilement la guerre du carabak
bon lorsque on voit la multiplication la
diplomatie turque en Afrique de l'Ouest
il n'y a pas que la Russie qui nous
cause des problèmes en Afrique de
l'Ouest il y a aussi la Turquie donc je
pense que c'est un véritable rapport
conflictuel si ce n'est que à la
différence de du président Erdogan le
président Macron ne se laisse pas aller
à des invectives voilà c'est tout Claude
Gubal ou je reviens vers vous Claude
gibal je vous la parole juste après
Claude Gubal bon finalement vous êtes
arrivé jusqu'au Sénat mais vous restez
dans le taxi c'est beaucoup plus simple
comme ça ça aurait été le feuilleton de
cette fin d'après-midi parce que là on
parlait de la relation entre le
président turc et Emmanuel Macron mais
il y a quand même dans dans l'actualité
de ces dernières 24 heures il y a ce
camouflé on peut dire ça comme ça que
recept Erdogan a a a envoyé euh Anthony
blinken au on va dire ministre des
Affaires étrangères des États-Unis au
secrétaire d'État américain il a refusé
de le rencontrer euh comment vous
l'expliquez
ça alors effectivement Anthony blinken
qui venait en en Turquie un petit peu
raccommoder les les les morceaux avec
cette allié turc à la fois très
compliqué dans l'OT temp enfin vraiment
le le mauvais élève de l'OTAN pour pour
les États-Unis et REP Tayip Erdogan a
prétexté un déplacement ailleurs dans le
pays pour ne pas le retrouver en Ankara
il faut dire que REP Tayip Erdogan n'a
pas apprécié le fait que au début de de
de cette guerre ces efforts de médiation
hein vous savez que les dans les heures
qui ont suivi le le début de l'attaque
du du du Hamas Erdogan a dit être en
contact pour négocier la la libération
des des otages et on voit que la
médiation s'est plutôt faite en
s'appuyant donc essentiellement sur le
Qatar mais aussi mais aussi l'Égypte et
et et Erdogan n'a pas apprécié d'être
comme ça mis de mis de côté par les
États-Unis qui font pression sur lui
pour que il le parlement turc vote
l'adhésion leur accord pour l'adhésion
de de de la Suède à l'OTAN il y a ce
contentieux militaire entre eux de vente
de vente d'armes et et R Tayip Erdogan
on vient de le rappeler c'est un c'est
donc c'est un joueur de de bgeman donc
c'est quelqu' qui utilise les
circonstances c'est un pragmatique et
c'est quelqu'un qui ne voit les
relations internationales que dans des
rapports de force on le voit avec
Emmanuel Macron on le voit on l'a vu
avec Bachar al-Assad à une époque avec
l'Arabie Saoudite et donc ce rapport de
force il va en jouer il sait aujourd'hui
qu'il a un rapport un rapport de force à
à à à jouer avec les États-Unis et à
manifester à continuer à manifester son
opposition puisqu'on ne veut pas le
faire rentrer dans le jeu lui il va
prendre le contrepied de ce jeu une fois
de plus euh il faut se souvenir que la
la matrice politique de Erdogan c'est
l'anti-impérialisme et l'antioccident
donc qui est lui plutôt le le marqueur
de de son de du fondateur de la
République turque ataturque et donc RB
Tayip Erdogan là c'est qu'il doit jouer
en fait cette cette carte j'allais dire
presque des non aligné face à
l'alignement
occidental perçu par par lui et par les
Turcs comme pro-israélien ou un tout
dernier mot très rapide Didier bon on
est au cœur de cette
désoccidentalisation dont vous parlez
dans votre livre mais est-ce que le le
je reviens à la toute première question
de l'hypothèse d'un processus de paix
est-ce que l'initiative peut pas venir
de là justement c'estàdire de ce Sud
global je sais pas si ce serait la Chine
l'Arabie Saoudite ou la Turquie en
quelques mots vraiment quelques secondes
ce serait évidemment souhaitable enfin
d'où que vienne l'initiative elle est de
toute façon souhaitable sauf que le sud
global expression que je n'utilise
jamais au demeurant ce sont des Suds il
n'y a pas un projet politique vous avez
remarqué que ces dernières semaines les
chinois sont quand même extrêmement
discrets sur cette crise à Gaza que les
Russes essaye d'instrumentaliser
celle-ci pour se remettre dans le jeu
international et donc malheureusement je
ne crois pas que à ce stade en tout cas
ce sud ou ces Sud soit en situation de
prendre des initiatives efficientes et
efficaces merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat j'ai
rappelé les titres de vos livres
Jean-François colosimau le sabre et le
turban qui est aux éditions du bons
désoccidentalisation repenser l'ordre du
monde aux éditions Agon merci Claude
gibal et désolé de ce de de cet épisode
d'un taxi parisien voilà ça arrive dans
l'histoire d'une émission je vous dis à
très vite que demain et jeudi soirée
spécial consacré au texte immigration
ici examiné au Sénat noté également que
l'invité de la matinale demain ce sera
Antoine Basbous le fondateur et
directeur de l'Observatoire des pays
arabes belle
soirée